on vient idéologiquement de casser le
cadre collectif de votre emploi et
derrière ça on vous dit vous avez un
employeur qui refusent un représentant
des employeurs qui refuse de négocier la
convention collective ou plutôt qui va
vous donner quelques queues de cerises
et on vous dit vous prenez ça sans vous
mobiliser sans essayer de vous défendre
moi je trouve parfaitement cohérent que
dans les assemblées générales l'immense
majorité des cheminots décide de
poursuivre la mobilisation moins de
dépenses est pas parce qu elle ne se
traduit pas en capacité d'être encore en
grève alors qu'ils le sont depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il n'y a pas une
vraie rancoeur qu'il n'y a pas une vraie
colère qu'il n'y a pas une vraie
amertume et qu'est ce qu'on préfère une
grève ou des opérations qu'ils soient
des opérations on va dire violentes ou
dépôt opération à un moment donné de
casse du matériel ou de je ne sais pas
quoi oui et bien qu'ils poussent à cette
situation la journée un phallus mais
bien sûr c'est de la radicalité la
radicalité du mouvement parce qu'on ne
reconnaît pas les organisations
syndicales est la plus fortement
on refuse simplement ce que nous
demandons depuis des semaines à savoir
négocier ou renégocier l'expansion et
l'évolution de ce conflit une logique de
radicalité que la prochaine fois ce soit
pas une semi ce qu'ils soient arrachés
voilà c'est